it's Christmas Day and hundreds of
indigenous Quechua people have come to
the village of San Antonio say Cortez to
say goodbye to seven-year-old Jacqueline
Cod Jacqueline and her father left this
remote Guatemalan community on December
1st and headed north to the United
States in search of the American dream
but a week and nearly 2,000 miles later
the family's dream of a better life
turned to tragedy one Markkula action
girl now also can show conoces ajik
North Dakota early detection of etiology
- okay ah who's really quite all
seriously right - Goodman in Anoka
Johnny Jacqueline died in u.s. Border
Patrol custody 27 hours after she and
her father were detained her mother
Claudia is now living every parent's
nightmare attack a couple cambio
traditional Makana for decades my akechi
communities like Jacqueline's face
oppression and systemic displacement buy
us back dictators and now African palm
is spreading across the fertile plains
near the carl's community some
substances farmers have sold their small
parcels to the palm oil companies others
say they were pressured or even
threatened to sell whatever the reason
the result is less available land for
growing corn Jacqueline's father nari
saw the plantations as a rare
opportunity to get a decent job he and
his brother Carlos secured work
harvesting palm fruits on a local
plantation but they discovered that the
promising job was based on exploitation
I'm honestly getting a lock what kind of
transient gets us cut the Rita energy
returns in Montrose our to do one
different thing gets a low mark Cahokia
capita knocked over by up rare enough or
they're poor carry interesting monica
bhanu chander zzz elda skaters
Jacqueline's grandfather Domingo Cal has
worked the land his entire life he grows
cacao and spices and has planted a
variety of fruit trees on the family
plots of land but one crop is central to
the lives of indigenous gotta balance
and this staple is now under threat
hablando en cambio clemontic s porky
carita cannabis masculine uncle Te'o
viendo iCal oh yeah no it's c'mon
farmers like Domingo say it's impossible
to know when to plant their saved corn
seeds as weather patterns have become
less predictable droughts and flooding
can decimate crops and government
assistance is non-existent and every
year there's more pressure on the land
muriel mice is important
pero a yo no se welcome quest como se
llama ante por que antes he said abba
tada when he is he a CMS milpa pero en
da ya know say ya know serum buena se da
pero poco por que por que ella tiene
esta cansá
and total eso se que ya know say when
demand mice see no consumer when farmers
like Domingo managed to produce more
corn than their families consume they
sell the eggs
in local markets half a year ago one
hundred pound sacks all for roughly
sixteen dollars now
farmers are lucky to get just half that
that makes purchasing beans meat and
vegetables much more difficult this lack
of a steady jobs combined with smaller
corn harvests and disappearing land
means families like Claudia's are faced
with the most difficult decision a
parent can make with his options running
out nari felt trapped desperate to find
some way forward cincuenta feel good
with my name thank you listen when they
get their toll when conquering cash
register
nari wasn't the only one from this
surrounding area looking towards the
United States the local mayor says that
200 families have left for the border in
the past two months some traveling with
up to five children estamos bien SE
flucos a personas para appearances algo
para me you know via visto si Claro
Nestle Arman tell numero de de familias
que si amigo piranhas to salty Menezes
preocupado organizer rocks caulk works
in local qexg communities he has seen
firsthand the impact of migration on
indigenous values and culture he tries
to convince families like the girls that
there are alternatives to migration but
he says he's fighting a losing battle as
human smugglers take advantage of
people's ignorance and desperation esta
época mister
Pando mucho que por que muchos Archie's
estan en de personas que vienen a
promotion are como se fueron producto de
vente a bowl an Tiaras tone de anunciar
que era Estados Unidos viaje seguro
trabajo seguro compresses Komodos los
coyotes contra tan promoters comunitario
gente de la comunidad pero lo
contraremos ok estoy couch ando a un
cierto precio cuando yebin los Nino's
porque es más fácil que la una pieza de
Sciglio en estados unidos syllabus une
no estan co grande ont treinta y cinco
Cuarenta meal quetzales pero SI te vas
day mojado Jose a condo no debe no
passes en la migration directamente
mojado know Ava's ninguna no Cobra endo
tchen tehy cinco noventa mil Quetzales
the Cal family won't say how much nari
paid for his trip or whether the Kaori
gave him a discount for taking shuttling
along but if he is the porter there will
be large debts to pay take in D 2 min
under me
dooshka I'm Terry King familiar sister
to plea to min chaotic in until cash
there but knock up stick Aria cardi 2
min now genic mark I doubt it
talked enough keep the only to me now
and a Chapman tacky
Neri Cal planned to travel to the United
States alone
but when Jacqueline found out he was
leaving she told her father she wanted
to go to she had a special bond with her
father and didn't want to get left
behind
no Kona's cannibalistic watch
Alma's narada's Palace - quanto basta
mas Nutella Steve Arkell Trujillo
Christmas cottage in a car approaches my
enemy I envision a massage Oh Logan
gutiar Tanaka crowd oohs Allan Poe dalla
lana kane karush Guerrero yo Porco's
lanky Jenna in an aquatic Spiro Knox :
le rue
dos kilpatt yaroslav muchacha que bueno
todd worrell
knock'em knock'em addict which are
Chanticleer unit idea was not negating
logic rain that will have its Pagliarulo
nakulan a mnemonic errant mcmahon
captain Keith and Karen October in
silica calibers movement comically rude
the group reaches the tiny cemetery
where Jacqueline's family built a basic
tomb over the past few days
Jacqueline's uncle Carlos writes her
name in the fresh concrete ensuring that
though she might be gone she will never
be forgotten
you